Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's eine leckere Oreo Torte.
Mein Papa z.B. der liebt Oreos und ich habe ihm letztens
als er Frührentner geworden ist, hab ich ihm eine Oreo Torte gemacht,
das habt ihr im Vlog gesehen und habt gesagt: "Kiki, die musst du uns doch mal zeigen!"
Und da habt ihr vollkommen recht!
Die ist gar nicht mal so kompliziert aber dafür richtig, richtig köstlich.
Ich hab jetzt hier schonmal vorbereitet meinen Schokoladenbiskuit Boden.
Dafür gibt's ein extra Video damit dieses Video auch nicht so lang gehalten ist und ihr darauf immer zurückgreifen könnt.
Dann brauchen wir natürlich Oreos, hier hab ich noch etwas Kakao(ganz normalen Trink-Kakao) für die Böden.
Mascarpone, Vanilleextrakt und Sahnefest.
Hier hab ich Puderzucker und Schlagsahne.
So und jetzt beginnen wir mit der Schlagsahne.
Tipp Nr.1: die Schlagsahne muss ganz frisch also ganz kalt aus dem Kühlschrank kommen.
(H: Und das muss auch kalt sein!)
Genau das wollt ich auch grad sagen, du hast mich jetzt richtig erschrocken!
(H: Also das hier..Wie heißt das nochmal? Schneebesen?)
Ganz genau, Hamza hat's schon gelernt!
Also der Schneebesenaufsatz und die Schüssel bestenfalls auch für 10-20min in den Kühlschrank stellen,
es ist ein fataler Fehler wenn ihr das z.B. gerade heiß wascht oder so und dann hier drauf legt
dann wird die Sahne auf jeden Fall gerinnen, die wird auf jeden Fall nicht steif.
Daher diese Tipps beherzigen! Jetzt geb ich die Sahne in die Maschine,
schlag die so ungefähr 30sek an und geb dann 8TL Sahnefest dazu.
Und dann auf höchster Stufe vollständig steif schlagen.
So, die Sahne ist schön steif geschlagen! Wir verwenden sie jetzt sofort weiter.
Würdet ihr euch jetzt ein bisschen Zeit lassen, dann gebt die Sahne auf jeden Fall in den Kühlschrank.
Aber ich beeile mich jetzt, daher ist es kein Problem, wenn sie ne Minute hier steht.
Jetzt gebe ich Mascarpone in eine große Rührschüssel zusammen mit dem Puderzucker
und dem Vanilleextrakt und da kommt auch noch mal ein bisschen Sahnefest rein.
Ich rühr das Ganze dann mit einem Schneebesen um und hebe dann
die Sahne mit meinem Teigschaber unter.
So fluffig ist unsere Creme! Die wird gleich noch aufgepimpt
und das Tolle ist: ich benutz die jetzt zum Befüllen, zum Bestreichen und für die Sahnehäubchen!
Also wir haben hier 3 in 1 quasi!
Wichtig ist: jetzt die Creme in den Kühlschrank geben!
Das mache ich jetzt sofort und nutze aber die Zeit, um dann die Oeros,
die Kekse der Oreos von der weißen Creme zu befreien.
Die weiße Creme brauchen wir in diesem Rezept nicht, aber nicht wegschmeißen!
Das könnt ihr euch ja aufbewahren und in irgendwas anderes weiterverarbeiten
oder einfach so naschen. Und dann geht's auch schon weiter!
Den Großteil der Oreos hab ich jetzt in einem Blender ganz, ganz fein gemahlen,
und einen kleinen Teil hab ich nur grob geschnitten, das brauch ich dann später für die äußere Deko.
Und falls ihr euch jetzt wundert: "Kiki, wie viel brauchen wir denn von alldem?",
ich schreibe euch immer die ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Videobeschreibung,
einfach neben dem Titel den Pfeil anklicken und dann gelangt ihr direkt dorthin.
Und jetzt hab ich hier meinen Schokobiskuit Boden und der wird jetzt 2 Mal durchgeschnitten,
sodass wir 3 Böden erhalten.
Schaut euch den Boden an, richtig feinporig!
Den hab ich gestern Abend vorgebacken und der ist einfach der Beste!
Also wie gesagt, auch das Rezept verlinke ich euch in die Videobeschreibung!
So, jetzt hab ich mir die Creme aus dem Kühlschrank geholt
und gebe einen Teil, also gerade so ein bisschen weniger als die Hälfte
in meine Schüssel - also in eine separate Schüssel - und geb da die gecrushten Oreo Kekse rein,
denn das ist unsere Füllung.
Für außen brauchen wir dann wieder eine weiße Creme, eine helle Creme
ohne die Oreo Kekse, daher mach ich das alles immer gerne separat.
Die Oreofüllung ist fertig und ich hab die restliche Creme auch schon wieder in den Kühlschrank gepackt,
denn der Kühlschrank ist heute unser Freund!
Also damit ihr echt nicht zuhause verzweifelt: immer wieder kühlen!
Und ich nehme jetzt hier wieder mein Konstrukt...ich hab immer mein Konstrukt,
wenn ich Torten mache!
Und zwar besteht das aus meiner drehbaren Tortenplatte (die hier aus Glas),
dann hab ich hier die Tortenplatte, auf der die Torte serviert wird,
und meinem Tortenring damit auch alles schön gerade an den Seiten nach oben geht.
(H: Du Architektin, du!)
Naja!
Und ich mach das jetzt so, dass ich mir einen Boden nehme und ich tränke den ja jetzt mit dem Trink-Kakao
einfach so damit ich's so ein bisschen schokoladiger hab, könnt ihr auch drauf verzichten.
Also an sich sind die Böden jetzt nicht trocken sondern super super saftig und lecker.
Und da geb ich jetzt ein bisschen Trink-Kakao obendrauf, geb dann die Oreofüllung dazu
und dann schichten wir das bis wir mit dem letzten Boden abschließen.
Jetzt ist die Torte befüllt und ich geb da jetzt damit die Oberfläche auch nicht austrocknet
mein Cakeport oben drauf (*Replay*: Cakeport, Cakeport)
(H: CakeBOARD!)
...mein Cakeboard obendrauf.
Und so geb ich jetzt meine Torte für ½h in den Kühlschrank,
danach lösen wir den Tortenring und werden sie rundherum einstreichen.
Aber das zeig ich euch gleich auch nochmal ganz in Ruhe!
So ihr Lieben, nach der Kühlzeit mit einem Tortenringmesser am Rand entlang fahren,
damit da auch nichts mehr am Tortenring kleben bleibt wenn ihr ihn entfernt.
Und jetzt nehm ich ihn einmal weg von der Torte
und bestreiche sie mit der weißen Creme.
Ich liebe diesen Moment!
Sieht dann immer so gut aus!
Nach dem Einstreichen wird die Torte für 2h in den Kühlschrank gegeben und dann kümmern wir uns um die Deko!
Die Kühlzeit ist wichtig ihr Lieben damit das Ganze ein bisschen fester wird und wir jetzt
den Schokodrip ganz einfach drüber geben können, ohne dass irgendetwas verläuft.
Und für den Schokodrip hab ich hier schon was vorbereitet:
und zwar hab ich Zartbitterkuvertüre und Butter in der Mikrowelle bei geringster Wattzahl geschmolzen
und jetzt verrühr ich das und dann geb ich einfach den Drip auf die Torte!
Jetzt lassen wir den Schokodrip einmal ganz kurz aushärten,
ich geb das jetzt einfach in den Kühlschrank für ca 10-15min
und dann spritze ich mit meiner Rosentülle richtig schöne Tupfer auf die Torte mit der restlichen Creme,
ihr solltet nämlich auf jeden Fall für die Tupfer noch was übrig haben laut meiner Berechnung.
Und dann geb ich nur noch halbe Oreos drauf und dekoriere den Rand
mit meinen klein gehackten Oreos...ich werde immer langsamer,
das ist immer wenn ich mich auf was freue, rede ich einfach immer langsamer
und genieße die Sätze die ich sage!
Richtig verrückt!
(H: *lacht*)
Also ihr seht gleich die Deko und dann schneiden wir zusammen an!
Und fertig ist die perfekte Oreo Torte!
Ich finde nicht, dass eine Oreo Torte immer hoch und mächtig sein muss,
sondern einfach auch mal locker-leicht!
Wir haben ja jetzt die Sahne-Mascarpone Creme
und innen auch mit den Oreo Keksen aufgepeppt.
Und was ich wichtig finde: der Boden. Ich hab jetzt extra nicht meinen saftigen Schokoboden genommen,
der ist zwar lecker aber ich habe extra drauf verzichtet und den locker-leichten Schokobiskuit genommen
damit die Torte nicht so schwer ist und eure Gäste nicht sagen:
"Ach Mensch! Die liegt jetzt aber richtig schwer im Magen!"
Nein, also so ist sie definitiv nicht und
(H: Ich glaub davor haben die meisten Angst!)
Ja davor haben die meisten Angst, das ist echt so!
Die fragen auch immer: "Kiki, da ist doch Sahne und so.."
Nee das ist garnicht so!
(H: Aber die ist doch auch nicht so hoch jetzt die Torte!)
Genau, die ist schön niedrig diesmal gehalten und überhaupt nicht deftig.
Also macht sie unbedingt nach wenn ihr Fans von Oreo Torten seid.
Ich muss euch ganz ehrlich sagen: Oeros an sich snacke ich nie, reizt mich gar nicht so
aber in Torten verarbeitet find ich's richtig lecker!
(H: Und bei den Cremes!)
Vor allem in Cremes, ganz genau!
Und wenn ihr jetzt noch ein paar Geburtstagskerzen oben drauf packt, dann habt ihr die perfekte Geburtstagstorte!
(H: Mhm, das stimmt!)
Ne? Oder?
(H: Ja!)
Also ich find das sieht einfach nur hübsch aus,
unbedingt nachmachen!
Schaut in die Videobeschreibung wie gesagt für alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben
und wenn ihr bis hierhin geschaut habt und euch die Torte anspricht,
dann hinterlasst doch gerne jetzt ein Däumchen nach oben
damit ihr uns auch was zurückgebt.
Und in die Kommentare bitte die nächsten Wünsche!
Dann kann ich drauf eingehen und kann was nächste was- *stammelt*...das nächste Mal was zaubern!
So! Ich bin jetzt ganz aufgeregt wegen der Torte weil wir gleich auch naschen werden,
aber euch verabschiede ich jetzt erstmal und sage: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen!
Tschüss!